hey guys it's Wednesday April 27th I'm
Mary and you're watching gamespot news
and what a day for news it is we've got
rumors we've got thievery we've got
release dates roll that intro do you
guys remember that leak from yesterday
when we learned that Cod's new name
would be infinite warfare well the leaks
now been upgraded to a drippy faucet
because now we know it's going also be
included modern warfare remastered call
of duty infinite warfare which is
reportedly the name of this year's entry
in Activision's first-person shooter
series will include a remastered version
of call of duty modern warfare according
to an image of the pre-order card the
image was posted on reddit and it looks
to be from us retailer target it shows a
cover for the legacy edition of the game
and states the package also includes
call of duty modern warfare remastered a
November fourth 2016 release date was
also prominently displayed whoops again
none of this has been confirmed by
Activision yet who are probably not
happy that their new game has been
revealed I wouldn't be surprised if they
confirmed this one very soon Nathan
Drake got a taste of his own medicine
this week as a bunch of copies of
uncharted 4 were stolen in the UK that's
right uncharted 4 release date was
broken in the UK because copies of the
game were stolen on Tuesday reports
emerged showing that copies of the
highly anticipated PlayStation 4 game
for being traded in the UK some two
weeks before it's official release
explaining the broken street date
PlayStation games development director
Shuhei Yoshida said in a blog post that
a number of copies of uncharted 4 Athey
send were stolen he said Sony was
working with the police as part of a
criminal investigation he also warned
fans that the broken release date might
result in spoilers we know that many of
you have been looking forward with great
anticipation and excitement to the
latest masterpiece from Naughty Dog
Yoshida said from what I've played of
Nathan Drake's latest adventure I can
tell you that it's very much worth the
wait uncharted 4 is expected to be the
final game in the series developed by
naughty dog and the final one starring
Nathan Drake the uncharted 4 release
date is May tenth following several
delays to the project finally we all
knew that the Nintendo NX was right
around the corner now we know very close
when my bday next year Nintendo has
confirmed that its upcoming gaming
console codenamed and
X will be launching globally in March
2017 the information was revealed as
part of the company's 2016 fiscal year
earnings report released today the NX
release date was also confirmed by a
post from the official nintendo america
twitter account the report reads for our
dedicated video game platform business
nintendo is currently developing a
gaming platform codenamed NX with a
brand-new concept and x will be
launching in march 2017 globally no
further details about the NX or the
consoles concept or the design were
revealed that's all you get what a
bummer Nintendo first announced plans
for new console in March 2015 in related
news nintendo announced the upcoming new
Legend of Zelda game will be released
simultaneously for the wii u + NX in
2017 pushing the game's launch date
further away from its original 2015
release the company also revealed it
will be releasing fire emblem and Animal
Crossing games for mobile devices
expanding its repertoire for apps
following the release of the me tomo
social networking app oh that was a lot
of news but we're done for today I'll
see you guys again tomorrow for more
often GameSpot news have a good one